non
c'est une grande filmé dans les petits
tas
ouais
dans leur bébé elle est valide comme une
crise de nerfs pour soi etc ou pas
alors moi je me suis levé j'ai été des
journées
j'avais pas très très fort parce que
j'étais très ému de ma nouvelle mettrait
jamais peur cheveux pâles à quelques
jaillir à boire vous avez peur et le
client d'être revenu à l'école alors
vous n'étiez pas contente en vacances à
bon très gentil je trouve et est très
jolie aussi si elle est sévère je sais
pas encore parce que pour le moment elle
est très gentil je trouve mais
et aujourd'hui pour la rentrée j'ai
l'impression que vous êtes un peu en
avance non oui c'est parce qu'elle ne
veut venir en avance
ça rajeunit ça donne l'impression d'être
connais pas encore le
complètement en dehors de la vie active
quitter l'as nancy frère et ses voûtes
les accompagner et pourquoi vous
l'accompagnez bas puisqu'ils vont faire
une mauvaise rencontre
je vous assure que pour nourrir ce
serait de l'animation les clients
surtout oui ça fait de l'animation la
pagaille il est gauche pour taper dans
les vitrines
et puis ce show must go oui ça vous fait
plaisir de revoir tous les gens sont en
effet sir de revoir mes enfants ça fait
déjà deux mois et demi pour nous
apporter